russia's government has ordered alexi
navalny's political organization to shut
down for now
the leading opponent of president
vladimir putin just ended a nearly
three-week hunger strike in prison
as elizabeth palmer reports navalny
supporters had used his
action as a springboard for new
anti-government protests
here's what the prosecutors want to shut
down
alexey navalny's powerful movement which
is focused opposition to vladimir putin
especially
among the young navalny himself was the
victim of an assassination attempt last
summer with a nerve agent
he blames the kremlin the kremlin denies
it
but as soon as navalny recovered from
treatment in germany and returned to
russia
he was sent to jail now a court wants to
silence his anti-corruption foundation
too by labeling them extremists on a par
with isis and al qaeda
vladimir ashurkov is the foundation's
director
why are they so afraid of you i guess
because
over years navalny and our organization
emerged as the most important opponents
to vladimir putin
the foundation has consistently exposed
corruption in putin's circles
most recently in this video of a vast
country estate allegedly built
for the president it's had more than 150
million views and featured gold-plated
toilet brushes which went
viral as a social media joke and became
a mocking fixture in demonstrations
the kremlin tries to ignore navalny
president putin won't even say his name
but the ruthless measures taken to
repress him in his movement may backfire
and in fact
add to his fame and support as navalny's
wife julia wrote in a letter to cbs
news's 60 minutes
whatever comes next alex a has already
won
nevertheless that extremist designation
would be a real setback for a start
navalny's organization would not be
allowed to participate in the coming
parliamentary elections anthony
elizabeth palmer in london thank you liz